we have got some really big breaking
news the really big breaking news of
course is that Jack Daniels has gone
drag
this right after Bud Light was caught
sponsoring a transvestite Dylan Mulvaney
a lot of pushback against this well Jack
Daniels a while ago I guess sponsored
this drag campaign people have dug that
up and now they're given Jack the old
Bud Light treatment
party to plan and we need to go get some
decorations yeah we need to get this
going honey we're expecting people my
God she looks
ready
[Music]
we should make a jackfire cranberry yes
Jack fire cranberry
still a lowball glass with ice you have
one and a half ounces of Jack fire with
four ounces of cranberry juice
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you get the idea it goes on
for a little while now
everyone's criticizing Jack Daniels
especially on the right
I however don't have a huge problem with
this I don't have a huge problem I have
a huge problem with Bud Light I have
less of a huge problem with this because
it's not that Jack is advertising their
regular Jack Daniels here it's not good
old number seven okay it's not that Jack
is advertising their Gentleman Jack
their higher end whiskey you saw the
specific product that they are
advertising here is Jack fire it's their
ripoff of Fireball cinnamon flavored
whiskey
and
100 of the people who drink Jack fire
are at least homosexuals at least they
might be trans they might be drag queens
they might it's a not it's not a ever
it's not a heterosexual beverage I don't
even think women really drink it I think
if women are going to drink take a shot
of one of these kind of frou-frou
cinnamon things they'll probably just
drink Fireball Jack has that bite to it
it's more of a man's drink
albeit a man who's a little bit light in
his Lynchburg loafers so in this case
you have Jack Daniels marketing a fopish
drink to a foppish crowd of people
all right that's it fair enough right
that's not that doesn't offend me
what it what offends me is when Bud
Light
Mark it's a drink that is only consumed
by frat stars and construction workers
and dudes at baseball games
and markets that to transvestites who
actually claim to be women and who
who dance around and make awful
caricatures of women all the time that
bugs me that that's a real finger in the
eye of the customer base of Bud Light
but for Jack that's okay I don't mind so
as long as they don't do a toll number
seven I don't really that's okay that's
fine it fits it fits I don't mind when
weird cultural movements
or at least coherent or semi-coherent
what bothers me is when the
LGBT gay stapo just tries to colonize
everything else
and they try to go in and take normal
products you know sports bras from Nike
and then put them on this dude and say
you know just do it no I don't want to
do that I don't do that
or when
drag queens go in and they start
jiggling for Elementary School students
drag queens if you're gonna have a drag
queen show that belongs in a weird part
of town and some weird kind of CD
Cabaret late at night with a guy
checking IDs at the door if you're gonna
have it at all it certainly doesn't
belong
in
elementary schools
that's the real that's the real issue
here
speaking of fopish fellows
returning to 2016 as well the libs are
having a meltdown the libs are just so
so angry they're addicted to Trump they
can't quit him but they're so angry at
him they're scarred by him Chris Hayes
over on MSNBC
he's giving his analysis of what
Republicans should be doing vis-a-vis
Trump after having been scarred in 2016.
there are lots of people who watch
politics closely who've got a lot of
anxiety stemming from that 2016 election
and probably will for as long as they
live I know I will everywhere you look
the signs point to the fact that Donald
Trump is incredibly unpopular with
persuadable voters outside the
Republican base
but everyone is so freaked out so
permanently scarred by 2016 that obvious
truth is often obscured
and the truth is that Donald Trump
Listen to Me Now does not possess a
magic power that turns political gravity
upside down
he is an unlikelable figure who lots of
persuadable Voters find repulsive at
some point
Republicans are going to have to face
this reality
eyes utterly toxic
as long as you keep supporting him
you're gonna lose a lot of winnable
elections Donald Trump is so terrible
and everyone hates him and you better
not run him for president
says Chris Hayes the big lib on the big
live Network don't do it Republicans
to me Trump is terrible and he's awful
and you're gonna lose if you don't do
what I say get rid of trump
I hate him so
I don't know he's kind of convincing me
that Trump's the guy
if if MSNBC
out of such concern for the Republican
party's electoral viability
MSNBC says look we really have your best
interests at heart Republicans I really
look I want Republicans to win elections
I know I'm a lifelong Democrat and my
whole network exists just to get
Republicans out of elected life but I'm
look I'm taking a break from that I'm
really concerned for you I'm just
telling you you you'd be crazy to
nominate that guy Trump he's he's a so
easy to beat that guy is so easy to beat
for president that we're trying to
arrest him in three different locales in
America to keep him from campaigning yo
because he's so easy you know you get
him out there and the more people see of
trump the more they're going to hate his
guts that's why we're doing everything
we can to shut him up and keep him off
the campaign Trail and ideally just put
him behind bars
right does that make sense to you
it doesn't make sense to me I don't know
and the the permanent scarring that's
the key too
the key is
that the political class which is mostly
liberal But it includes some squishes in
establishment Republican types
it was Unthinkable to them
that Trump could be elected
it was Unthinkable it was traumatizing
to them
because
the the options for America
we've got the far left over here
we got the center left over here and the
options were supposed to be between
those two poles
and that was it well and it's okay and
sometimes sometimes you get a bush and
sometimes you get a Clinton but you know
it's a well and we'll complain about it
but you know those are the options and
then when you had someone come in and
say actually no you guys are wrong on
trade you're wrong on foreign policy
you're wrong on abortion you're wrong on
manufacturing you're wrong on all of it
that was that that short-circuited the
liberal class
I'm not saying Trump can win in 2024
they might just say nope we're not going
to let you win even if even if 80 of the
people vote for you we're not going to
let you win again but
it does show you the real
threat that guy posed how many years
later are we seven years later they
still can't get this man out of their
head he haunts their dreams the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it become a member and use code
Knowles Canada wlas a check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign